let Maurice Ashley has our winner the
champion of the Paris French head store
Maxine by Sheila Grove the winner here
in Paris 2019 Grantchester
rapid and blitz the maximum but Sheila
Grove and we will now introduce Jill
Beth Hauser who is the CEO of Collier's
a sponsor of the event and many other
wonderful events Jill take it away I'm
very pleased to hand out this trophy to
Maxim Congrats first victory in in Paris
very happy to welcome you at this stage
thank you very much and Maxime let's
talk about this event first of all the
sense of joy that you must feel winning
here in your home city I mean it is joy
of course but right now it's mostly
relief because today and even yesterday
was something of our show and I'm ready
not pleased with the way played at least
of course I won in the end so it's
really really relief but it's too soon
to call it joy the feeling of winning in
front of your friends family and fans
yes that definitely once it kicks in
the wage hitting the overall standings
as well for the Grantchester all you
really needed to do well here and when I
interviewed you before the tournament
you said I've got a win mission
accomplished
yeah mission accomplished it was not all
that smooth and yeah I think I should
have worked it up even yesterday so you
know it's still good
any final words for the sponsors or
everything the organizers of the
tournament yeah different race I think
the event is yours they were organized I
appreciated the fact that so this time
so was access for spectators so thank
you to colleagues and vivendi for for
putting on this show all right well
there you have it and once again
congratulations to max him on fantastic
event the winner in power is here Maxine
by Sheila Groff couldn't have done any
better in front of the French fans again
for the French I'll add a blue and we
are gonna say goodbye here from Paris
Bravo and here is our winner Maxine by
telegraph 13 grand Chester clients
all smiles and vichy on and his fans can
certainly be cheering to because we did
not expect this taking home 25 k and 10
g CT points